moi c'est Leïla j'ai 12 ans et j'habite
dans la Vienne
[Musique]
quand les matins papa est le premier à
quitter la maison en ce moment il
travaille sur un nouveau chantier
[Musique]
on a beaucoup de chance d'avoir un
département qui engage des gros projets
sur le territoire ces chantiers sont
précieux pour les entreprises locales du
BTP
cette année j'ai fait ma rentrée en 6e
j'avais hâte de découvrir mon collège il
est tout neuf et très beau
lui c'est Armand il a un chauffeur
de classe sont géniales
[Musique]
qui me rend heureuse c'est travailler
des produits frais de qualité et de
faire découvrir aux élèves de nouvelles
saveurs en mangeant local
elle a 3 ans il a trop de voix qu'elle a
rendez-vous ici moi mon médecin il est
juste à côté de la maison et aussi un
dentiste mais j'aime vraiment pas ça
l'accompagnement du département m'a
permis de m'orienter vers des
territoires en besoins c'était
financière à l'installation et précieuse
elle m'a aidé à financer le matériel
nécessaire pour débuter mon activité et
j'ai ainsi pu bénéficier d'un
accompagnement pour visiter mes futurs
locaux
quand on rentre dans l'école ma petite
sœur s'endort
[Musique]
après mes devoirs le mercredi on
retrouve souvent avec Hobbit pour jouer
elle c'est Valentine et cette année
allez élu au conseil départemental des
Jeunes je me suis présentée au conseil
départemental des Jeunes pour porter des
projets à réaliser ensemble je veux être
la porte-parole des jeunes
moi j'aimerais aider les gens
[Musique]
lui c'est mon papy et vient souvent
devoir parler de vacances c'est trop la
chance de le voir
[Musique]
on va souvent visite à mon
arrière-grand-mère à la maison de
retraite
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé un métier passionnant plein
d'humanité et de coeur et j'ai la chance
de travailler dans un bel établissement
on retrouve cette humanité et cette
proximité
on va souvent avoir des concerts et des
maths
j'ai même vu l'équipe de France de hand
et la pique et c'était à l'Arena
j'adore le sport
[Musique]
il y a dans ce département une vraie
dynamique en faveur du sport je me sens
soutenu et confiant pour préparer mes
prochaines échéances internationales
on adore se balader dans la nature
[Musique]
et plus
il y a plein d'activités dans la Vienne
qu'on en profite à fond
[Musique]